[Music]
[Applause]
let's bring in Peter King football
morning in America columnist and uh whoa
Pete on the road USC Colorado on
Saturday what brought you all the way to
Boulder Colorado
Dan you know
one of the things I tell young
journalists when I talk to them at
colleges is one of the things you have
to have to do this job is to be curious
and aren't we all curious I mean I met
CeCe Sabathia on the sidelines of
uh you know on the Colorado Sidelines
before the game and I said what are you
doing he goes I I love Dion I grew up
loving this guy I just had to see this
and I mean I kind of felt almost exactly
the same I just had to see it and it's
just it's totally fascinating from
talking to tailgaters who are incredible
pragmatists at 6 25 a.m I mean it was a
10 a.m Mountain game
um and so I thought the coolest thing
though of the weekend I mean there are a
lot of cool things Shadow Sanders Dan is
going to play in the NFL for a long time
and he's going to be good
I I was really impressed with him but I
thought one of the coolest things is
the USC wake-up call at their hotel in
Denver to play in this 10 a.m Mountain
Time game the USC wake-up call was 4 40
a.m
and uh you know so it was which is 3 40
a.m on their body clocks so you know as
I wrote in my column this is just a
taste of what they're gonna get when
they go to Columbus and fox says you're
playing the big noon game this week so
you know it was interesting on a lot of
fronts who do you think has a bigger
upside though and I maybe this isn't
fair to ask you uh but Caleb Williams or
Shadow Sanders when it comes to next
level
I came away more impressed we should do
our Sanders because he does more of the
things you're gonna have to do at least
look Dan I'm not a college football nut
I don't know I watch one game I watch
one game
but I do know that I saw a lot of
evidence in this one game that shador
Sanders could really be extremely good
he's he processes very very well he's
got a great arm throwing it on the Run
he's incredibly confident he's got his
father's confidence
uh and he made a couple of throws in
this game that you just say you know his
touchdown pass in the fourth quarter on
Fourth and five rolling out there was no
window there was no space at all and he
completed it now look
Caleb Williams
you know he has all the time in the
world yeah you know as I as I said that
on that long pass that he threw for a
touchdown that he threw across his body
he had 7.42 seconds to throw in Patrick
mahomes's career seven years 17 times in
his career he's had 7.42 seconds or more
to throw it just it rarely happens in
the NFL so I'm saying celebrate the guy
and I'm sure that he's going to be a
good Pro but all I can say is he's got a
lot of advantages that shoulder Sanders
does not have
do you think that Dion's style can
translate into success in the NFL if he
would want to do that
that's a great question I think you know
he's obviously insistent he told Rich
Eisen that he wasn't going to the NFL
and all that I just keep wondering what
happens when Jerry Jones shows up in
Boulder in three years and said it's
your destiny you need to coach the
Cowboys
um I who knows I I don't know but I do
think
the one advantage that Dion has at
Colorado is if he chooses he can get a
new team every year
he's just going for he that's what he
did this year he's got a new team and he
can do the exact same thing this off
season he needs an offensive line and he
needs a couple of pass rushers he'll
find him because everybody wants to play
for Dion when he got all these musicians
and star athletes on the sidelines
I I mean a lot of these guys look at a
lot of the recruits and players look at
these guys and say why wouldn't I want
to come here he's Peter King football
morning in America columnist and of
course contributes to football night in
America you can find his column
nbcsports.com worst loss of the weekend
in the NFL was
who
I think I think there were two that were
tied I think the the Bears loss was
awful because it exposed so many cracks
on their team and in their organization
you know you have this gamer Justin
fields for the first time in a long time
plays great now he turns it over a
couple times in the second half but
overall that was a b-plus performance
that was absolutely terrific
and I guess I look at it and I say it
just shows that look they've you know
they've lost now what 14 games in a row
I don't see how Matt eberfloof survives
and now you get this Chase Claypool
thing bubbling up but the other really
bad loss I thought
was Washington through very little fault
of its own
um the commanders I thought played
absolutely valiantly in the last two
years in Philadelphia they they're one
and one in Philly and they've outscored
the Eagles in you know at Lincoln
Financial Field this is a good team and
the quarterback Dan yesterday he had he
had a great day I said Sam Howell's
numbers weren't the best but he had a
great day and and I just think I think
Washington I don't know if it'll be this
year it'll be soon I think they're going
to be troubled for people because that
defense is legitimate
what about the Bengals
I mean what do you expect now you know I
chuckled during the week when I was
reading stuff about okay well you know
look at the Bengals now they got a
couple of games they can win they're
playing Tennessee they're playing I
think Arizona they got a couple games
they can win hey look people look at the
Bengals now and say for we got the
Bengals we can beat them
Dan I had a note in my column this
morning that in 21 and 22 Joe Burrows
threw a touchdown pass every 16 pass
attempts
this year he's throwing a touchdown pass
every 76 pass attempts yeah and he's
just not Joe burrow so the question is
should you gut it out
and look Dan I heard you talk before
about we'll just get to the buy let them
get healthy and everything there's no
indication at all that he's going to be
healthy if you just give him two weeks
to do nothing but rehab
so I I'm not really sure that that's
that that is the way to go I think this
is going to be an injury that unless you
give them six or eight weeks off it's
going to plague him the whole year yeah
but that's what I said a couple of weeks
ago that let him get healthy if if the
doctor says hey if you take a month off
you're going to be able to be healthier
if not then it doesn't make any sense
whatsoever
um watching the bills and the Dolphins
like what what uh stands out that you
think is sustainable for either one of
these after that performance
I talked to Sean McDermott after the
game and he said to me that
it was really he said I've been in the
NFL for a while he said that was the
most amazing crowd I've heard I've never
heard more noise in an NFL stadium and
he goes shout out to Bill's Mafia
[Laughter]
I think two things number one
you know Josh Allen was really really
good because Dan you remember a couple
of times this year he's taken way too
many hits and he's taken way too many
chances with the ball but I thought that
he played the game exactly right he
didn't take he wasn't in one Collision a
legit Collision on the field and I
thought his decision making was pristine
and look when when you've got Stefon
Diggs playing at the top of his game
which he was yesterday you know he
reminds me so much of Michael Irvin
because he is able to be physical he is
he has got the utmost confidence in what
he does and when he broke that tackle
and ran for the 55-yard touchdown I just
said that has got to be on his career
highlight tape because that's who he is
he says get off me you bum you know I
mean that's just and that's the way
Michael urge even used to be I always
thought what I call Michael Irvin is the
best physical wide receiver I've ever
seen and Stefan Diggs is in his League
I'm watching the Cowboys they're blowing
out the Patriots and you can have
questions about you know what's the
future there of their coach and
quarterback but seven minutes to go why
is Micah Parsons still in the game why
is Jack Prescott still in the game
I don't know the answer to that I really
can't answer it
um I'd be listening in a 17 Game season
I say this about guys like Debo Samuel
Micah Micah Parsons all the time I
basically say listen you're just you're
risking when you've got a 20 plus point
lead Midway through the fourth quarter
you got to get as many people out as you
can for a very simple reason because
you're just sort of you know challenging
the injury gods
and and especially with guys like
Parsons who doesn't know any other speed
he's Dan a couple of weeks ago I said
this and I got an incredible amount of
crab for it but to me you know I covered
Lawrence Taylor for four years in the
80s and Micah Parsons is the closest
thing I've seen to him I'm not saying
he's better I'm really not I'm saying
that Parsons does the most things like
Lauren Taylor of anybody I've seen in
all the intervening years and to me
the Cowboys should do everything
possible when they're up by 20 or more
you know chain him to the bench I mean
you know lose his helmet you know he
shouldn't he shouldn't be playing and
and I understand I feel the same way
really about Dak Prescott
is Bill
Belichick fireable
there's only one person who knows that
maybe two Robert and Jonathan Kraft
um I don't think it's going to come to
that I don't think Robert Kraft would
ever want to do that and I think there
would be some sort of golden handshake
with him and Bill but again I don't know
Dan
it's easy to sit here and say that Bill
Belichick's coached 498 NFL games and
that was his worst loss there this is
going to be the fourth straight year
they won't win a playoff game I mean
it'd be a shock if they rebounded to
make the playoffs
so I don't know Dan at some point I
think Robert Kraft is gonna stop being
sentimental and Gauzy and longing for
the old days and saying listen we gotta
win now and the guy who's the coach and
the procurer of talent has not done a
really good job so I I think that at
least it's not out of the question I
have no idea if it's going to happen
great to talk to you again Pete thanks
for joining us okay all the best Dan
thank you Peter King football morning in
America nbcsports.com